now Sudan has been marking a year since
the overthrow of dictator Omar al-bashir
then there were high hopes that the
north east african nation would overcome
30 years of corruption and economic
decline but a year on those hopes are a
long way from being fulfilled on top of
economic stagnation the country's also
dealing with swarms of locusts eating
the crops and the corona virus pandemic
dwae Ibrahim has been catching up with a
friend she made there during those heady
days of revolution it was a moment of
relief and euphoria April 11 2019
protesters in Sudan's capital celebrate
the removal of dictator Omar al-bashir
the months they'd rest their lives on
the streets had not been in vain it was
there and then that I met Mohammed who
made a photographer in the middle of the
revolution my pictures are for the
coming generations the experience of the
people in my photos should not be
forgotten it was a time of violence
authorities often attacked the
protesters the government has to bring
justice to the people that died we are
alive because of them everything that
has happened is because they sacrificed
their lives those now considered murders
by many are not forgotten but their
families have not yet seen prosecutions
I asked Prime Minister ham doc about
this issue back in February the
constitutional document which is guiding
this transitional period has a very
clear undertaking that will establish an
investigation committee so let us not
jump to conclusion and
humm duck heads a new government that
was sworn in in August after a
transitional deal was struck between
civilians in the military as Beshear is
in prison for corruption while his
former ruling party has been dissolved
Sudanese officials have suggested they
might even turn him over to the
International Criminal Court for trial
over alleged war crimes committed in
Darfur yet Sudan's economy is still dire
and attempts to improve things are
hindered by the country's continued
presence on the USA's list of state
sponsors of terrorism many young people
who protested and celebrated a year ago
have moved abroad in search of a job
Mohamed now lives and works in the
United Arab Emirates I wanted to stay in
my country with my family but there were
very little opportunities this is a time
when Sudan especially needs us he might
not be able to be at home to mark the
anniversary but like millions of
Sudanese the heady days of Hope in April
2019 will be etched in their memory for
a lifetime joins us now welcome yeah so
a year since Omar Bashir was toppled
what's the mood insider'
I think there's quite a bit of
frustration for a number of reasons
first Sudanese people can't go out and
celebrate the first year anniversary of
this you know very emotional day for
them because of the coronavirus
restrictions but there are also a lot of
frustrations because of the economic
situation you know as we mentioned
Sudan's economy was already doing very
badly and you know crisis after crisis
has exacerbated these problems but
they're also frustration with a number
of issues related to the transition
themselves and itself and I think chief
among those is the issue of
investigation into violence used by
authorities alleged violence used by
authorities against protesters during
the period of the uprising that's
contentious it do do protestors expect
to get justice then
I mean the civilian government has
signal time and time again that it is
working on it as the Prime Minister and
the piece indicated there is a committee
that has been established to look into
this violence but this committee has
really taken a lot of time they've
delayed the report by three months with
no results and what's frustrating about
this is that for a lot of protesters
there's no doubt about it they've seen
you know security forces attack attack
protesters especially on June 3rd when
they broke up the protest camp but also
it's not just the authorities that are
looking to these protests there have
been multiple journalistic investigative
works in the past year that have shown
evidence that you know clear as day who
was involved and also a lot of NGOs have
presented a lot of evidence so a lot of
protesters are saying well these people
have the evidence what are you doing why
don't we have results I'm what is the
suspicion there is it the it's a
suspicion that the civilian side is sort
of that being outgunned as it were by
the military or is it an attempt just to
suppress that I mean this I mean we can
speculate we can guess we have some
pretty good clues as to why so one you
know armed group called the rapid
support forces which a lot of protesters
really believed was you know involved in
the violence against business this was a
regime force yes the leader of the rapid
support forces is someone who is sitting
on the sovereign council someone who is
still very much involved in the running
of Sudan makes public appearances so you
know it begs the question of well if
they really do take this seriously isn't
there a conflict of interest in the
people that are now you know part of the
regime but I will say that there is a
there's also a recognition among
protesters that you know they've they
look around and they see Sudan kind of
still at a relatively peaceful stage
because civilians and military forces
were able to find a compromise when you
look at other parts of the Middle East
where this couldn't happen this couldn't
happen
the military has gotten way too involved
and then you know a lot of the
accomplishments of these uprisings were
totally taken back just just on that
idea of holding people to account or
we've we've heard this year that
Sudanese officials have said that they
want to
and their former leader over to the the
ICC the International Criminal Court in
The Hague for alleged war crimes in
Darfur so where is that up to well this
announcement actually came in the
context of the internal peace talks in
Darfur that the transitional government
is now holding with rebels in Darfur and
this was very very important to the
Darfur ease that this become that this
happens that all murdered Bashir does
answer to his crimes in front of the ICC
what they didn't do is that they didn't
specify if he was going to appear in The
Hague if he was going to be extradited
so to speak or if it would be an ICC
complicit
I'm sorry compliant court in the region
in Sudan and they basically just made
that announcement they said he would
appear and there wasn't really a lot of
follow-up but a lot of people that I've
spoken to say it's very unlikely that
he's going to be extradited because that
would definitely raise a lot of eyebrows
from his henchmen who are complicit in
his crimes of course alleged crimes GW
reporter heir Ibrahim thank you